[Música]
el descontento llenó las calles de
colombia la prohibición judicial a causa
de la situación epidemiológica no detuvo
el rechazo masivo a la reforma
tributaria propuesta por el presidente
duque que busca subir los impuestos a
los ingresos medios y grabar algunos
productos de la canasta básica nos
quiere cobrar impuestos e iba por
absolutamente todo le va a poner libra y
va la canasta familiar a los costos
funerarios a la gasolina a todo porque
eso es lo que quiere el gobierno que el
pueblo colombiano no salga a marchar y
la excusa es que hay como vides que hay
virus pero no hay virus más grande que
el mismo gobierno colombiano comunicó a
todos los de la tercera edad no le
tengan miedo la pandemia tengamos miedo
a la reforma a quitar esos y tengamos
miedo si el pueblo colombiano no lucha
no vamos a seguir adelante y nos van a
clavar una reforma totalmente arbitraria
que nos va a llevar a aguantar hambre
empobrecer más el pueblo y eso es lo que
no queremos
en general la jornada se desarrolló de
forma pacífica
pero por la tarde se registraron
incidentes en varias ciudades en bogotá
la capital cargaron las fuerzas
antidisturbios y un grupo intentó
tomarse las instalaciones de un canal de
televisión local en la ciudad de cali
fueron vandalizados varios autobuses y
se produjeron saqueos a locales
comerciales
las movilizaciones siguen la estela de
las de 2019 y reflejan la desigualdad en
el país donde la pobreza afecta casi al
40% de la población según la cepal el
destino de la reforma es incierto así
como el de colombia camino a las
elecciones presidenciales de 2022